since four months back I was visiting
this as East African city and so I was
stuck in traffic and this vendor
suddenly approaches my window we didn't
have opened alphabet sheets I took a
quick look at the alphabet sheet and I
thought of my daughter how it would be
nice to spread it on the floor and just
play all over it with her while getting
her to learn the alphabets so the
traffic moved a bit and I quickly
grabbed a copy you know and we moved on
when I had time to fully open the
alphabet sheet and take a more detailed
look at it I knew I was not going to use
that to teach my daughter
I regretted my purchase why so looking
at the alphabet she reminded me of the
fact that not much has changed in the
education curricula in Africa some
decades but I was taught out of a
similar alphabet sheet and because of
that I struggled for years I struggled
to reconcile my reality with the formal
education I received in school the
schools I attended I had identity crisis
I looked down on my reality I I looked
at my ancestry I looked at 1980 with
disrespect I had very little patience
for what my life had to offer around me
why it is for Apple it is for Apple a is
for Apple is for that child in that part
of the world where apples grow out who
has an apple in her lunch bag who goes
to the grocery store with her mom and
sees red green yellow
you know apples of all shapes and colors
and sizes and so introducing education
to this child with an alphabet sheet
like this
fulfills one of the major functions of
Education which is to introduce the
learner to an appreciation of the
learners environment and a curiosity to
explore more in order to add value in my
own case when and where I grew up in
Africa Apple was an exotic fruit two
three times a year I could get some no
yellowish apples with brown dots you
know signifying thousands of miles
traveled warehouse distorting to get to
me I grew up in the city to very
financially you know comfortable pairing
so it was my dignified reality exactly
the same way cassava fufu or googly
would not regularly feature in an
American Chinese or Indian diet Apple
didn't count as part of my reality so
what did this to me what what what
introducing education to me with AIDS
for Apple net education and abstraction
he made it something out of my reach a
foreign concept a phenomenon for which I
would have to constantly and perpetually
sit the validation of does it belong to
for me to make progress within it and we
did that was tough for a child he would
be tough for anyone as I grew up and I
advanced academically my reality was
further separated from my education in
history I was taught that the Scottish
Explorer Mungo Park discovered the Niger
River and so it bothered me my
great-great grandparents grew up quite
close to the edge of the Niger River and
me it took someone to travel thousands
of miles from Europe to discover a river
right under their nose
what did they do with their time claim
what games roasting fresh hams fighting
tribal wars I mean I I just knew my
education was preparing me to go
somewhere else and practice and give to
another environment that it belonged to
you was not for my environment where and
where I grew up and this continued this
philosophy on that guided my studies all
through the time I studied in Africa it
took a lot of experiences and some
studies for me to begin to have a change
of mindset and I will show a couple of
the remarkable ones with us I was in the
United States in Washington DC studying
towards my doctorate and I got this
consultancy position with the World Bank
Africa region and so I remember one day
my boss know we were having a
conversation about you on some project
and he mentioned a particular World Bank
project a large-scale irrigation project
that cost millions of dollars in the
jury public that was faltering
sustainably he said this this project
wasn't so sustainable and you know he
bothered those that instituted know the
whole package but then he mentioned a
particular project a particular
traditional irrigation method that was
hugely successful in the same nigiri
public where the World Bank project was
failing and had got me thinking and so I
did further research and I found out
about taza taza is a traditional
irrigation method where 20 to 30
centimeter wide and 20 to 30 centimeter
deep holes dog across a field to be
cultivated and then a small dam is
constructed around the field and then
crops are planted across the surface
area what happened is that when
rainwater from rain falls the holes are
able to store the water and approach
to the extent that the plant needs you
know the water the chant can only
assimilate as much water as needed onto
your harvest time nija is some of the
75% scorched desert so this is something
that is a life-or-death situation is
being used for centuries in an
experiment that was conducted a plot of
land two similar plots of land were
using the experiments and one plot of
land did not have the tossa technique on
it similar plots the other one had was a
technique constructed on it
then similar grains of millet also were
planted on both plots during harvest
time the plot of land without such a
technique yielded 11 kilograms of
millets per hectare the plot of land
with Tesla technique you did five
hundred and fifty three kilograms of
millet per hectare I looked at another
station I eluted myself I said I studied
agriculture for twelve years from
primary to new to senior six as we say
in East Africa ss3 in West Africa or
twelve Drake no one ever taught me of
any form of traditional African
knowledge of cultivation of harvesting
of anything that will work in modern
times and actually succeed where
something imported from the West would
struggle you know to succeed that was
when I knew the challenge the challenge
of Africa's curricula and I am truss
began my quest to dedicate my life
concern my life work to study in
conducting research on Africa's own
knowledge system and then being able to
advocate for its mainstreaming in
education in research policy across
sectors and industries another
conversation and experience I had at the
bank
I guess made me take that final decision
of where I was going to go even though
it wasn't the most lucrative research to
go into bed it just about what I
believed in and so one day my boss
said that he likes to go to Africa to
negotiate or bank loans unto weapon
World Bank projects and I want no
intrigue they asked him why he said oh
when I go to Africa it's not easy I just
do I write off my loan my loan documents
and my project proposal in Washington DC
I go to Africa and they all just get
signed I get the best deal and I'm back
back to base I know I my bosses are
happy with me but then he said I hate
going to Asia or he mentioned it but a
black country in Asia and some of these
countries they kept me for you know days
trying to squeeze get the best deal for
their countries they get the best deal
they tell me how that Clause will not
work for us in our environment in our in
our you know it's not our reality isn't
it's just it's so Western and they tell
me oh we have enough experts to take
care of this you don't have enough
expect expertise we know and and they
don't keep going through all this in by
the time they finish yes they get the
best deal but I'm so exhausted and I
don't get the best deal for the bank and
we're in business
really I thought in my head okay I was
privileged to sit in on a loan
negotiating session in an African
country so I would do this consultancy
position during summer you know since I
was you know doctoral student and then I
traveled in you know with the team with
the World Bank team as more like you
know someone to help out with
organizational matters but I I started
during the negotiating session I had
mostly you know Americans you know with
me from Washington DC and I looked
across the table at my African brothers
and sisters I could see intimidation on
their faces they didn't believe they had
anything to offer the great-great
grandchildren of megapack the owners of
Apple in a is for Apple they just sat
and watched an oh just give us let us
sign you under knowledge you know it all
just where do we sign show us let us
sign they couldn't even they have no
voice they didn't believe in themselves
excuse me
and so
I have been doing this for a decade I
have been conducting research on
Africans knowledge system original
authentic traditional knowledge in the
few cases where this has been
implemented in Africa has been
remarkable successes record it I think
I've gotcha gotcha
is a is Rhonda's traditional judicial
system that was used after the genocide
in 1994 when the genocide ended Rhonda's
national code system was in shambles no
judges no lawyers to try hundreds of
thousands of genocide cases so
government of Rwanda came up with this
idea to resuscitate a traditional
judicial system known as Kotecha katachi
is a community-based judicial system
where community members come together to
elect men and women of proven integrity
to try cases of crimes committed within
these communities so by the time kotecha
concluded its trial of genocide cases in
2012 12,000 community-based courts had
tried approximately 1.2 million cases
that's a record
most importantly is that gotcha
emphasized Rhonda's traditional
philosophy of reconciliation and
reintegration as against you know the
whole punitive and banishment idea that
on the guards were present there
western-style and not to be not to
compare but just to say that we really
emphasized rundas traditional method of
philosophy and so it was male mu Julius
Nyerere a former president of Tanzania
to say that you cannot develop people
people will have to develop themselves I
agree with Molly moon I am convinced
that Africa is for that transformation
Africa's advancement recently in the
acknowledgement validation and
mainstreaming of Africa's own
traditional authentic original
indigenous knowledge in education in
research in policymaking
and across sectors this is not going to
be easy for Africa is not going to be
easy for a people used to being told how
to think what to do how to go about it
a people long subjected to the
intellectual guidance and direction of
others be in the colonial masters aid
industry or international news media but
it is a test that we have to do to make
progress
I am strengthened by the words of Joseph
Shabalala found out the South African
choral group Ladysmith Black Mambazo he
said that the task ahead of us can never
ever be greater than the power within us
we can do it we can unlearn looking down
on ourselves we can learn to place value
on our reality and our knowledge thank
you a Santa son
okay
[Applause]
[Music]